muy bien en este vídeo vamos a
introducir las baterías doble am al
soporte de baterías el lado negativo va
contra el resorte y el lado positivo van
lejos de él esto nos permitirá sostener
mejor las baterías en su lugar porque
aplica un poco más de masa y ahora que
la energía puede fluir vamos a separar
estos cables para que no hagan
cortocircuito ahora vamos a poner una
gota de silicón caliente abajo justo
aquí en la esquina y otra en la otra
esquina y la gota debe de ser de la
mitad del tamaño de una moneda de 5
pesos así que después vamos a tomar
nuestros interruptores de un polo y dos
posiciones y vamos a fijarlos cerca del
90 grados entre uno y otro de manera que
estén alineados así y bueno queremos que
estén en contacto al final de estos
interruptores de un polo y doble
posición es decir que estén tocándose
uno con el otro en sus contactos
ahora estamos listos para el siguiente
paso